boys where have you been
just running errands that's it
you're sorry
somebody's wanted to get pizza and I
tried to talk him out of it yeah you
ratted us out hey don't use that word
that way I mean sorry Dad
hey guys if we weren't monsters that
were shunned by society and we could do
what we wanted what would you guys do go
to high school maybe get a girlfriend
can you imagine that not likely
karate teams I want to know everything
about you our dad is definitely not a
giant rat that makes me feel like he's a
rap
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we pick out
Superfly and then everyone will think
we're cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
huh I can't believe there are other
mutants you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we're gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
we can't stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my door
[Music]
my son Michelangelo you have hearts
Donatello you have wisdomness Raphael
you have bravery and Leonardo honor
talk I dream about fighting every night
you've got a rage it's not a problem